do you remember when they first asked
you to host cuz it was such a random
thing right well yes I they uh they
asked me to host uh and they didn't know
what everybody was Flying Blind the
first year including me because I had
never been to a dog show I know know
anything about him they brought the old
English sheep dog up to the judge it you
don't know what an Old English sheep dog
is it's uh it's yeah it's 80 pounds of
hair and two pounds of actual dog yeah
so they brought it up to the judge who
was this elegantly gowned woman so she
walks around to the front of the dog and
she starts picking through all of the
hair on the dog's head and I said David
what is she doing now he says John she's
trying to find the
eyes to gauge the attentiveness of the
dog I said really I said well she picks
through all of that hair and she finds
only one eye she's got the wrong end of
the
dog so you see how far my learning curve
was you said it on air right oh yeah I
love you so much and and it turned into
the you know they have the broadcaster
comments in the sports section in USA
Today that was it wrong into the dog
John
[Laughter]
okay so you have a you have such a great
voice so have you ever done do you want
to I think dog wants to go for a
[Applause]
walk hi God I love you so
much she said she said to the dog turn
around come back take them back oh my
God for your morning out for your
morning Constitution were you physical
comedy is the best oh my God I love you
so much now don't you try
that uh be sure to watch the national
dog show tomorrow along with my sister
who never misses it Thanksgiving Day on
[Music]
[Applause]
NBC
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home